so I was telling Justine about this a
week maybe a couple months ago that i
pre-ordered it I got an email and they
were like hey we want to send you one of
these and I was like oh so we're hoping
that it's gonna be awesome because we've
used some other AR thing so we didn't
even tell you that yeah but needs like
what it is it's kind of like virtual
reality except instead of like that
being a screen instead you see the
things in your living room so we're
gonna be a fighting like Darth Maul
right here we're probably gonna have to
go downstairs cuz you guys can't tell
but this is there's no room here so the
cool thing is you can use a phone but
what I'm worried about is because the
new iPhone 10 just came out but do you
think they have compatibility for yeah I
know
so when you and you and Jenna and all
your sisters were a little was there
every Christmas so you're like she got
the better gift now really because my
mom was always very careful to make sure
that we each got either like one thing
that we wanted or we all have the same
like we used to have like all the
American Girl dolls my sisters have the
Bratz dolls they love those ones
freaking awesome look at that oh there's
also an owner so don't get wicked close
when you open it up did you smell that
it kind of smells like Home Depot there
was that line Oh your stuff smelled all
right drew charge it what are the
battery recommendations there's a switch
on the bottom I am really excited than
that for something just charge through
like a little micro USB at the bottom as
well see and then there's this little
thing here I don't know what that does
but it feels like it's some things I'm
already
yeah she was like kind of skeptical and
I was like no a hundred percent so if
I'm wrong on this I think it's gonna
have negative marks on our friendship
no I think it'll be cool because I do
love all of like the VR and AR
experiences but have you been to the
IMAX we are in Los Angeles yeah it's so
cool this is our hats s thanks
that's a good quality like - oh gosh so
we're still gonna be able to see our
surroundings so this isn't a our than VR
yeah it's not the are at all and there's
a couple different games on here there's
lightsaber battling there's chess chess
yeah there's like Star Wars chest plate
like against each other oh so percent
I remember reading that they were
working on it and they weren't sure if
they were gonna have it for the launch
but that they were gonna have it I can't
make mine a little tighter mine fits
perfect I was meant for this ever since
I was a little kid I wanted to be a Jedi
and it's about to happen
I'm really glad I could be here to
experience yeah I was like I can't open
this alone Justine I'm freaking out I
was sitting on the couch playing call of
duty all morning and you're like I'm
coming over but you gotta give me at
least an hour because I'm rotting on the
couch right now she cleans up tonight I
don't I didn't know we were filming so
while I look good it's only by chance I
didn't plan on filming but then I was
like this has to be something we felt
yeah really cool it is really awesome
and it's just kind of like memorization
yeah these look like they're all
different cables or different phones and
there's a lightning one oh look how did
you do that lift it up Oh what did I
just do Oh
do we read directions or active-matrix
putting on the headset okay I'm already
getting really excited like I thought
well this looks like anything now I'm
like really excited
you're gonna start trusting me I don't
know I guess now there's so many words
so look there's a whiteness wanna walk
this is pink if I don't tell it for
energy line is a different color
look you can't there's two different
things so there's like a pink and a blue
download Jedi challenges searching for
Jedi challenges on the App Store that's
a good idea
I always forget that you can do that I
do too all right so that's what we're
gonna dart Vader is gonna be in our
living here you're living your model but
look at that
I'm not letting Darth Vader in my house
you can hang out I'm so happy
you think he's more you think he's like
a hangout he kind of guy for sure he'd
be like you follow me popcorn
okay the app is downloaded these are all
the steps down here is like 15 steps
there's a lot of steps and every time I
I feel like my watch is gonna get to
that point where it tells you your heart
rate is elev family you do that synched
calibrate the lightsaber all the
lightsaber parallel to the floor
I'm totally completely do those okay Oh
place the beacon on the floor oh boy so
should we take this on stairs now I feel
like we should okay
are we gonna bring them downstairs oh
yes okay here we go coming down yeah
we're gonna be we're gonna be a Jedi we
can even move this table so we lose the
kitchen table and now we're gonna set up
and see what happened but I just don't
notice because it said that I'm so happy
yes okay I won't even I met so we need
to figure this out because I'm worried
because we have a new iPhone Ted and
since this just came out that it isn't a
supported film which obviously I'm sure
it will be good say that it probably
will work but it might not and if it's
acting weird it's probably because you
don't have a support phone yeah but it's
okay it will be supported I'm sure okay
so you should probably do yours first
okay please be gone before leaving a
wide-area flag
how does this go in here what does that
attach to insert your phone inside the
tray face down and close the lid what's
happened I see a circle it's too big for
my head mm-hmm they can see it they can
see something yes they can see it this
is so cool it's like you know in Star
Wars when Princess Leia pops up out of
r2d2 it's exactly like that but I told
the Droid Wow and so they want you to
lose although we definitely lost all
hope mostly cuz I was right the new
iPhone wasn't gonna work properly but
then Alex was able to get his to work
basically perfect sounds like well let's
try the pixel and now we're trying to
pixel and then because Android is asking
for all these permissions and things and
some things are happening but we're
almost up and running remember one the
hardest thing to do with the toys figure
out where the batteries go yeah oh I
gotta get in front of it holy this is
yours this is yours give me my stick so
if you have two of these you can use the
same ball Wow
this is real heavy on my head I wish you
can see this because like what I lift on
my arm a freaking lightsaber is just
extended it's like I'm seeing it for
real life he's outside my range oh don't
worry I'll move forward I'm in challenge
to activate your lightsaber they're
getting so close to me I think I'm
right-handed
oh wait I'm left-handed well maybe
that's why I'm gonna bad black guys are
so far away my guys are like right here
oh why are all up here oh I think I just
cut your head off
look at this dude this is so great I'm
sorry I'm trying to save you I am no
longer gonna have a kitchen any longer
we're keeping that one getting rid of
the table see if I get close enough you
guys can kind of see what I'm seeing
you guys see it oh this guy's over here
oh we're going to say are you are you
still on the boo yeah me too
[Music]
why are my eyes so far up here what like
mine are all the way over here on the
other side of the kitchen oh okay I'm
getting I'm getting dizzy and it's kind
of crazy that you just need your phone
pretty much to make this work I know oh
okay I get motion sickness very very
easily so I'm going to take a break but
this is by far the most fun that I've
had in a really long time
yep this is great I love it I absolutely
love it I no longer have a kitchen this
is strictly only for generating its I'm
having the best time
little did I know the first time I
really the white say it would be able to
just be this cool in real life now so
we've decided that it's much cooler
place bar here
darken this for ya because basically
everything is illuminated way better
yeah is way harder oh yeah every meter
ya know she told me that I handled with
my lightsaber well that's it we had the
best time playing this game so hopefully
I'll be able to find some footage online
that I can show you guys what we're
actually seeing because it's so awesome
I'm so glad we got to play this thanks
Alex for going over
thanks for having me yeah what's your
channel yeah I depending about when I
post this we also did a really fun video
together we did the whisper challenge
that was the I did a bunch of games that
hey with a bunch of people and that was
the only one I was good at really yeah
just yorkers okay but you're good at it
but I still well what is happening oh
god oh my I'm getting a phone call
[Music]